well brian clark county wants your  opinion on how to use the 440 million  dollars from the american rescue plan  act  within our community so over the next  month there's going to be town hall  meetings showcasing some potential  programs  and office services that could be formed  from that money so the first meeting is  at six o'clock it's happening tonight at  the clark county government center  and there will be some public comment as  well an online survey will also be  available until july  21st how should we spend that money we  have a link to that and dates for  several others in person meetings on our  website for you  at 8newsnow.com